This is Tommy and JP
from InCamera,
who are a YouTube channel
and effects house
that make effects... for real.
Mhm.
And we're going to do a fire stunt.
We are. But we ourselves
are not going to conduct this stunt.
We have got a specific fire team in to do it,
'cause that's just what they do.
♪♪
Do not try this anywhere.
How're you feeling?
A bit nervous.
Three, two, one.
Did you know what you signed up for?!
Alright, put it out!
This is a very strange feeling.
Gel him up.
There's no going back now.
Absolutely Tom Scott's idea, yes.
One hundred percent.
Hold your breath. Ignite him.
And three, two, one, action!
When you go, you're probably just
gonna wanna go straight away.
(laughs)
The fake Tom Scott video.
So the sort of premise is that
we have JP and Tommy from InCamera,
have come to show Tom Scott
some pyrotechnics.
A spark goes off, which we've rigged.
They go to investigate.
Tom has a leaky can of
a flammable liquid,
which he puts down.
A second spark goes off,
which "ignites" Tom.
Tom comes up
with his arm on fire, realises it,
shakes to try and put it out,
comes running at the table,
through the set, past the cast and crew,
and then will collapse...
roughly where I'm standing,
where our very expert safety team
will put him out nice and safely.
Out! Put him out, put him out!
(imitates extinguisher)
Thank you for bringing all the
pyrotechnics and buttons and things along.
I know you're not gonna be
the actual person lighting me up here.
No.
But, what have you brought?
What's the plot we're doing here?
Well, so yeah,
we're setting up the gag.
We're doing the setup, essentially.
And so we've got a couple of things.
We wanna show you how we make
some miniature pyrotechnics.
But also to lead us into the burn...
we've brought some very—
again, quite simple, little spark hits.
Which we remote trigger
with something like this,
which looks, you know...
who doesn't want that?
It's the greatest remote control
that's ever been.
And you turn it on with a key.
With an actual key.
Yus! Come on!
That's lovely.
That looks like a prop. That looks like
something you've made for your channel.
There's actually just someone
on an iPad in the back(!)
But you wanna go...
I'm not sure I believe that's a real...
I know, I know. I understand.
But it is. You'll have to trust us.
Alright, alright.
And then that sends a little...
a signal to this.
It's like a receiver pack.
It looks like a prop.
It looks like something
out of a sci-fi show.
But that's literally made so that
people can wear it as costume,
so they can literally
have it on there.
You can use them for squibs, bullet hits.
Oh, so like, boom-boom-boom.
Things like that, boom-boom-boom.
So they could either hide that
within a costume,
or just on the belt around the back
if you can't see it.
But essentially, it's just—
It's a remote transmitter-receiver
type situation.
So this can just trigger any number
of little things, whatever they might be.
And in today's case,
that's gonna be some little sparks.
Yes. So we're setting up
the fake video here.
We're doing the fake introduction.
Yes.
We needed to come up with
some sort of ignition, basically.
Yes.
And fuel, which we haven't brought.
Something is going to go
deliberately wrong in the background.
Very much so.
So we're just establishing to the audience
that you are in fact competent,
and this is not—
Yeah well, this is it.
There's a weird meta-level to this.
I know! We had to put this scene together.
"How can we do this
so that something goes wrong
"but it's not looking like our fault,
'cause we're idiots?"
That was the balance,
the tightrope we had to walk.
But we still look like idiots.
Oh yeah, we still look like idiots.
We have to accept that
to a certain degree.
But yeah, so those are our
couple little tricks that we brought along,
that enable us to get into this...
serious business of setting you on fire(!)
Yeah. (cackles)
Why do you want to be set on fire, Tom?
I have seen the stunt in person
a couple of times.
At like... I can't remember...
Things like... Universal Studios will do
the live stunt show, will show off a burn.
And I realise that most people's
reaction to that is like,
"Oh, that's astonishing! I can't—"
My reaction to that was, "I wanna do that."
Wow, that's unusual. Okay.
I absolutely wanna do that.
Are you happy with this today?
Yeah.
I mean, this was my idea.
Good.
I've not been pressured into this.
Basically, we're gonna go through
the safety procedures later.
We're gonna make sure you're happy.
We can rehearse, rehearse,
rehearse, rehearse, rehearse.
Then rehearse again.
Go through all the safety procedures again.
And then... your arm's
gonna be set on fire here.
Your lower back and legs.
It will be quite warm.
Any problems, let me know,
and we'll abort.
So, it's gonna be...
arm, leg, lower back.
And presumably the flames
go up from there.
Yeah.
Right, okay.
We will do some testing
so you can see it,
so you can see where the flames are,
and the movement of the flames.
'cause obviously if you're moving around,
the flame's gonna be traveling the other side.
Just for you.
Right, okay.
And that's basically it.
I should be feeling cold
all the way through?
You shouldn't feel heat penetrating.
If you feel heat penetrating,
then we have to get
your clothes off very, very fast.
Right.
But that shouldn't happen.
I'm just pre-warning you just in case,
because we're playing with fire.
No, that's worth knowing.
I would have assumed that
I will feel radiant heat on me.
Yes. You will feel radiant head
on your face, back of your neck.
But try to avoid it.
Keep your face away from it.
As you can see, the flame's traveling,
and you don't wanna do too big a movement,
because the flame's gonna travel
and hit you in the face.
...Okay, right, good.
This is...
Sounds really bizarre,
but when flames hit you in the face,
it's like being punched.
It's that powerful.
Right.
It's really, really, really hard.
It will hit you, and you'll feel like
someone's just hit you straight on the nose.
So you'll want to avoid that
totally 100 percent.
That feels like
first-person experience there?
Yeah.
How much fire stuff have you done?
I've probably been set on fire fully
about fifteen, twenty times.
I've had arms set on fire.
I've had my head set on fire.
I've been on fire
thrown through explosions.
I did a full-fire job
and got spat out sideways
onto the floor.
And that was self-detonated.
I had to hold the detonator myself.
Hit it and get thrown
through an explosion.
That was quite gnarly.
So that is black powder or...?
No, this is asphaltum powder,
which is a derivative of a petroleum process.
It's a very fine powder,
and once it's... projected into the air
— and has enough oxygen amongst its particles —
will ignite in the air and self-burn,
and create a nice-looking
Hollywood-style fireball.
Right, okay.
The advantage of using these powders
is because they're not liquid,
we're not gonna get any of the
residual burning fluids and things like that,
that can be quite hazardous.
Alright.
So this is the test for whatever's...
I'm gonna be standing here with...
by the way—
with the completely fake and slightly-freaking-out-
our-safety-team "flammable liquid" can.
This is the one thing that
definitely doesn't have anything in it.
I'm gonna be standing here,
and this is gonna go off behind me.
Yeah. So this...
Okay.
It makes me twitch as well.
(chuckles)
So we're just gonna do
a quick initial test on this now.
So if I get you to step back
just a couple of steps...
(chuckles) How much, here?
Oh, that's more than fine.
I'll be closer than that.
Alright.
Okay, so.
Light this.
Okay, oh!
I only just worked—
You've got a bellows,
you push that, air goes under,
fwoomph, into the blowtorch.
That's right.
Right.
So effectively, we're...
...projecting the powder in the air.
And when it's within the air,
at this point, it's started its ignition,
and continue a fireball.
Alright.
Okay.
Is this gonna be loud?
It won't be loud.
You'll get a nice "woof", deep sound,
and hopefully a nice,
impressive-looking fireball.
So, we'll be firing in
three, two, one.
(puffy burst)
Ohh!
Nice smoke ring.
That's lovely!
It gives that kind of Hollywood,
rich, orangey-black rolling fireball.
And it's great for miniature effects,
because as you saw,
there's no residual burning.
It's not— That's a gunpowder smell.
No, no.
We're getting a test spark
to kick off now,
that JP is gonna fire
before we go for a real take.
JP, the floor is yours.
Thank you.
And we are test firing in
three, two, one.
(sharp bang)
(laughs uproariously)
There you go.
That was unexpected, right?
(inaudible)
I've...
I was expecting less than that.
I have a little afterimage there.
I didn't wanna look directly at that.
Are you okay there?
No, I'm fine!
I was expecting sparks
or like a (hisses)
Yeah. That was actually
less than I expected.
(group laughing)
Great!
Did you know what you signed up for
when you took the directing job on this(?)
Cool, alright. Spark's working.
We're good to go, team.
Can we have everyone
rolling up, please?
The whole day has been
building up to this afternoon.
We did the rest of the scene
this morning...
But right now is the main event.
We're about to get Tom...
all gelled up and ready to go.
We're all gathered and all ready.
Yep, we're gonna get you changed now.
We're gonna change your costume.
We're gonna wear 100% cotton,
'cause obviously that's flame retardant.
And we're gonna put some
fireproof underwear underneath,
to make sure you don't burn.
Are you happy?
Right, yeah.
Are you ready?
Ready as I'll ever be(!)
Let's go then.
Need this.
Oh, okay. This—
There's no preamble to that.
Just... so what is this stuff?
I know it as fire gel.
This is fire gel.
Okay.
I'm actually using this
more as a lubricant.
You've gotta get this on, okay?
Okay.
That's deeply unpleasant! (laughs)
I mean, the good news is,
it's the right size for me.
Perfect.
But that is... that's a lot of goo there.
There's two types of fire gel.
One's a protective barrier for him,
to protect his face
from the fire and the heat.
And one's the gel
that we actually set fire to.
Being set on fire obviously feels hot.
Different ways,
different methods of doing it.
He will be warm. He will be nervous.
But everything's gonna be
safe and happy.
This is a very strange feeling.
This is very strange,
because this is not my hand.
It's too big to be my hand.
It's too gnarly to be my hand.
And yet... I look at it...
and it's reacting like my hand,
because this is really flexible.
Yeah.
Obviously, when your arm's out
and it's on fire...
Any problems, we'll be there,
we'll put you out.
Alright.
If you don't like it...
raise your other hand up,
we'll put you straight out.
Okay. Happy.
Happy? Good.
It's good.
(inaudible)
I'm not feeling nervous yet.
I don't know if I should be.
You've been great at reassuring me.
This is 100 percent fine.
There's so many layers between
where the fire is going to be.
Because you won't be able to feel it,
you'll go, "Oh look, I'm on fire."
Don't, because it's still hot,
and you're gonna have to go,
"Whoa, [bleep], I'm on fire."
Okay, okay.
And you've got your own fireproof suit on.
Absolutely.
Right, so...
What order do we go in?
Basically, with special effects here,
they're gonna put some accelerant on here.
We're gonna ignite your arm.
Yep.
I'm gonna count one, two, three.
I want you to take a really deep breath.
I'm gonna hand over to special effects.
They're gonna put accelerant on your arms.
I'm gonna point to this gentleman,
who's going to ignite you.
Again, any problems,
lift this arm up.
Two firemen will come in,
put you straight out.
I'm gonna be here with you at all times,
making sure you're okay.
And don't breathe until
CO₂ is on and off.
Yes.
Alright.
Down there?
Just about there.
Yep. Ready to do it?
Take three deep breaths.
(breathes heavily)
(huffs)
Okay, go.
(muttering) two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight...
Ignite. Ten, eleven, twelve,
thirteen, fourteen,
fifteen, sixteen,
seventeen, eighteen, nineteen...
Come put him out.
Coming in. Move out of the way.
(extinguisher blows)
Breathe.
(exhales)
Look at me. Happy?
Yeah, happy.
That was very strange!
(crew applauding)
Alright!
I think we should get you rechanged.
Yep.
Rehearse, rehearse, rehearse,
then do the full burn.
Yeah.
Everybody happy with that?
Yeah. Let's do it.
Cool.
Come. This way.
Alright.
♪♪
I'm gonna say, "Are you ready?"
Ready. (huffs)
Six, seven, eight, nine,
ten, eleven, yeah.
Turn around, just once,
and then go.
(huffs)
Six, seven...
Ten.
Ten, eleven. Put him out!
And action!
(imitates extinguisher)
Really uncomfortable?
(falsetto) That is about half a size too small!
Good. If they're uncomfy,
you know it works.
(prosthetic glorps)
(chuckles)
And out.
Yep. There we go.
I've suddenly gained...
three sizes in every direction, but...
I wouldn't worry about it,
because when you're on fire...
nobody's really gonna give a (bleep)
(music ends)
I'd like one more rehearsal, please.
I wanna block that through one more time,
so it's absolutely locked in my head.
Okay.
And I think that's me actually rehearsing,
not me wanting to put off the moment,
'cause all the nerves just kicked in.
Walking away.
First position, deep breath!
Ignite!
Lighting it up.
Ready.
Action!
Put him out!
(imitates extinguisher)
Up.
(grunts)
Okay. Let's do it.
Let's do it, let's do it...
Do you hate me?
Yeah, I do.
That's really unpleasant.
But yeah, give me—
Thanks for that. (laughs)
(laughs)
Given the choice bet— betw—
I'm not pulling punches.
No, I wouldn't ask you to.
'Cause if you do, it might not be safe.
I hear that laughing!
I won't stop until...
Do it all in the back... (inaudible)
Eyes, nose, everywhere.
Yep.
Cool.
Okay, gel him up!
Coming up.
There's no going back now.
Keep your legs together.
Really breathe slowly.
Chill out, relax.
We're going for it now.
♪ (low ambient drone)
Walking away.
Okay, deep breath. First position.
Hold your breath. Ignite him!
Lighting up.
(climaxes into dramatic sting)
I got an email from
Tommy and JP at InCamera,
asking if I wanted to do some actual,
real-world pyrotechnic effects,
like in the movies,
which is what you do.
Yes, yeah. So we've brought
a selection of materials.
Thought we'd show you
some techniques that we use
to create miniature pyrotechnics
for films, yeah.
Alright. What are we gonna use?
We're gonna be using
a combination of powder effects.
No flammable liquids or
anything like that.
Oh yeah. No gas, no liquids—
Are you sure?
'Cause I got this special.
No-no-no, definitely not.
Especially not indoors.
Aw, okay.
We should—
(pop)
Is that meant to happen?
No, that's not good.
Um...
Okay.
Would you mind if we cut?
We should really check that.
Okay guys.
That's not good.
I'll take five for a little bit.
Okay, but like...
I think this is leaking?
Yeah, just pop it odwn.
We'll take care of it.
A—Are you sure? Aah!
(sharp bang)
♪♪
Put him out! Put him out! Put him out!
(extinguisher blows)
Up! (grunts)
(music fades out)
Come on, up, up, up.
Okay. I'm good, I'm good.
Don't care. Don't care. Outside.
Outside. Don't care.
Okay, okay, okay.
(pants)
(snickers)
(laughs triumphantly)
Thank you very much!
You're welcome.
(cackles)
Wow!
Honestly, my heart rate at this point...
That's the moment where
it got very, very real.
There we go, right.
Seen that.
That's an actual flamethrower.
That's...
(chuckles)
That's beautiful.
Wow!
(crew laughing)
And we cut into that.
Yeah.
Oh god...
(Tom and crew laugh)
Wow!
Well done. Well done.
That's good.
Thank you, everyone!
(crew cheers and applauds)
Right, I'm gonna
get a shower.
[Caption+ by JS*
caption.plus | @caption_plus]
Well done, guys!